but the president likes to have his
poster that said the mother reports up
this many days cuz this much money this
that and the other well we have a
corresponding competitor
a contradictory chart smaller
investigation by the numbers forty
million dollars recovered for the US
government remember he said how much it
would cost less than that thirty-seven
people and entities charged with crimes
twenty five ongoing criminal cases
referred seven convicted including five
top Trump campaign officials and then he
had no collusion no this event ten
instances of obstruction yes
no exoneration that's some of what we
heard today I just want to go to another
point at the same time as we're on this
path of the Muller investigation to
recognize that the Muller investigation
was prohibited from looking into the
president's finances and that is what
our Committees of jurisdiction had been
doing as we legislate for the good of
the American people were also
investigating so that we have the grist
for the mill to litigate in court and
those cases we've won in lower courts
they of course appealed we feel strongly
about our position about the position of
article one the legislative branch
having the right to have oversight over
the over every other branch of
government but that's important because
it means we can get the information to
show the American People what the
obstruction of justice was further all
about I'm very very proud of our
committees the Judiciary Committee and
his great chairman Jerry Nadler the
Intelligence Committee great committee
chairman Adam Schiff we're going to hear
from them now were also joined by Elijah
Cummings chair of the government was
forming Oversight Committee a committee
that is winning its courts in case as
well so I'm going to yield with great
was
but to all three of our chairman and
then we'll take some questions first
I'll yield to the sting was chairman of
the Judiciary Committee mr. nabban thank
you minute madam Speaker today the
American people heard directly about
what the Special Counsel investigation
uncovered as to Russia's interference in
the 2016 election and the president's
cooperation with it and obstruction of
justice
Mulla made clear that the president is
not exonerated Muller found evidence of
obstruction of justice and abuses of
power by the president he said the
report said the president could be
indicted for obstruction of justice
after he leaves office Muller found that
Trump would and did benefit from
Russia's help and that the campaign
welcomed that help
Mulla found multiple instances where all
three elements for charging criminal
obstruction of justice were met trying
to fire the special counsel in order to
stop the investigation trying to have
people lie and cover up for him for the
same purpose trying to limit or impede
or constrict the special counsels
investigation trying to tamper with
witnesses tamper with witnesses
cooperating with investigators all of
these were found with great evidence
President Trump went to great lengths to
obstruct the special counsels
investigation anyone else who acted in
this way if they were not the sitting
president would face criminal
prosecution would face indictments only
the office of legal counsels opinion
that you counted indict a sitting
president has saved or is saving the
president from indictment because all
the elements of of these crimes were
found with consider with with
substantial evidence and the people have
now heard this the president's chance of
no obstruction is nonsense his chant
that he's been totally exonerated is a
simple lie
first of all I want to thank director
Muller for a lifetime of service to the
country from his days as a young marine
in Vietnam through his decades of
service as a prosecutor as the director
of the FBI and through his service as
special counsel this nation owes him an
enormous debt of gratitude so director
Muller I want to thank you personally
for all of your service today the
director outlined in powerful words how
Russia intervened massively in our
election systematically in a sweeping
fashion how during the course of that
intervention they made multiple
approaches to the Trump campaign and far
from shunning that foreign involvement
in our election the Trump campaign
welcomed it made full use of it put it
into its communications and messaging
strategy and then lied about it
lied about it to cover it up lied about
it to obstruct the investigation into
that very attack on our democracy part
of what I found so powerful about his
testimony today was not just when he was
asked about the law but when he was
asked about the ethics the morality the
lack of patriotism of this conduct and
perhaps one of the most chilling moments
I think in our committee was when he
expressed the fear that this become the
new normal and of course I think what is
animating that fear of the director what
certainly and emits animates it for me
is the fact even after the nightmare of
the last two and a half years the
President of the United States will
still not forswear receiving foreign
help again that to this point the
president still continues to call this
Russian attack on our democracy a hoax
something that director Muller today
directly refuted that he still calls a
witch-hunt something that the director
Muller today directly refuted and so we
go into this next election more
vulnerable than we should be we can't
control completely what Russia does
although we must
everything we can to harden our election
defences to make sure there are paper
trails to make sure that we deter and
disrupt any kind of Russian intervention
but we cannot control that completely
but we can control what we do and
director Muller made it clear in no
uncertain terms that it's up to us
whether we act ethically and
patriotically whether we refuse to be a
party to a foreign attack on our
democracy and once again I thank him for
his service I first want to applaud a
chairman Nadler and who heads our
Judiciary Committee and certainly our
chairman of Intelligence Committee for
what they did today and their committees
what they did was paint a picture for
America one of the most chilling things
that I have noticed that did I witness
is when a member of former member of our
committee mr. Amash a Republican went to
a town hall meeting and got a round of
applause in the Republican district
after he said that he felt that the
president should be impeached but that
wasn't the thing that got me what really
got me was when a lady at the end of the
the town hall meeting said I didn't know
that there was anything negative in the
Mulla report about president Trump this
says a lot and to her credit I'll
speaker made it clear that we needed to
paint a picture for America for they
could so that they could fully
understand what is going on this is a
critical moment in our country's history
don't don't don't be fooled
and it is a moment which people will be
talking about and reading about three
four hundred five hundred years from now
and they're gonna ask the question what
did you do when we had a president who
who knew the rules and knew that our
founding fathers had done a great job of
creating a constitution and it put in
all the guardrails but never anticipate
that we would have a president that
would just throw away the guardrails and
that's why what happened today is so
critical it was a giant step in making
sure that the American people were got a
picture of all of this and hopefully
will look towards the future and say
we're not gonna have this both mr.
Nadler and mr. Schiff said something
that's very critical this isn't normal
and we've gotten so we're now getting so
used to normal to this kind of kind of
our president president and by the way
of alternate gentlemen and our
Republican colleagues that we it looks
like people are just gonna accept it
well we refuse to accept it and then in
my committee we constantly and I know
shifts and now we have heard this people
say oh you just messing with the
president because you don't like you
sided mouth not liking the president
it's about loving democracy it's about
loving our country it's about making a
difference for generations yet unborn
that's what this is all about and I'm
begging I'm begging the American people
to pay attention to what is going on
because if you want to have a democracy
intact for your children and your
children's children and generations yet
unborn we have got to guard this moment
this is our watch and again I am so so
very proud of Judiciary Committee I am
so very very proud of the Intelligence
Committee because they went in and tried
to pull out the facts soon as they could
paint the picture so did America I could
see it and hopefully they will not be
ladies like the lady and a marshes
town-hall meeting who says they didn't
know that there was something wrong that
drunk did with regard in his fellow
report and so again we we the speaker is
absolutely right she told us a little
bit earlier that she wants to gather all
the information and and and make sure
that we have everything we need to paint
that picture now what the American
people do it that's another thing but we
will not stand by and fail to give them
let them see the total picture I want to
thank I to thank mr. Muller for coming
forward for the service to our country
but well last but not least it is so
interesting that when mother would make
a decision that they liked is it all we
love you we love you you'll have your
the greatest thing in since I screamed
but then as soon as he said something
like oh you know were you you a bum come
on now we have to see through that thank
you as we acknowledge the greatness of
our chair Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff I
also want to acknowledge the greatness
of Elijah Cummings the chair of the
Government Reform and oversight
committee he has really won the first
case the maser decision which his
research enabled us to take the court we
won the case the decision was a complete
a beautiful statement on the ability of
Congress to have over sons but it just a
remarkable decision and now of course
the administration is appealing it but I
thank you too mr. Cummings for your
great leadership and and where we're
going next because as you know the
Muller
the Muller investigation could not do
the president's personal or business
connections and one of those connections
could be to the Russians and that's what
we want to find out so as we as we go to
questions I just want to say that I
think I do believe that what we saw
today was a very strong manifestation in
fact some would even say indictment of
this administration's cone of silence
and their cover-up this is on this is
about our sir
the oath we take to protect and defend
the Constitution but some of the actions
that the administration may have taken
we will see through our investigation
they have jeopardized our national
security by strengthening Russia's hand
and interfering in our elections
undermining democracy not only in our
country but in other countries as well
upsetting our preeminence as a democracy
in the world this is very serious today
was very important again salute our
Chairman all of our six chairmen who
have been involved in this and now it
can take some time
[Laughter]
as a mother of five I do my position has
always been whatever decision we made in
that regard would have to be done with
our strongest possible hand and we still
have some outstanding matters in the
courts it's about the Congress the
Constitution and the ports and we are
fighting the president in the courts I
don't know why they thought that they
came to me and I said I don't know why
yeah again the lawsuit says that we have
a number of lawsuit you want to speak to
that Giri well the very next step I'm
not going to talk longer-range the very
next step either tomorrow or Friday is
we're going into court to enforce to ask
for the grand jury material and to
enforce the subpoena against mr. McGann
and that's particularly important
because the excuses I won't call them
reasons the excuses that the white house
gives for McGann are testifying the
nonsense about absolute immunity
etcetera are the same excuses for all
the other fact witnesses and if we break
that will break the law Jim did I just
not say we're waiting to hear the from
the courts we have our subpoenas in the
court for and the subpoenas are for
information and we and when we get that
information we can make a judge you know
what we have several considerations it's
about what information is there and this
isn't endless
this isn't endless but understand that
but we have live cases in the courts we
have some that are going forward that
mr.
neither just mentioned there's an
endless but would strengthen our hand to
get that information remembering that in
the Watergate was when they got the
information in the tapes that broke the
case though isn't just about changing
public opinion that helped change public
opinion but it's not about me it's about
our caucus is about our country as I say
there's a cone of silence in the White
House that is engaged in a massive
cover-up and the obstruction of justice
those obstruction of justice charges and
as has been demonstrated today in the
hearings are could be indictable
offences by anybody else not the
President of the United States and the
president when he's no longer president
but the American people I think that if
we go down that path we should go in the
strongest possible way and that's all
I'm gonna say that the subject we have
our distinguished and I know
chairmanship and chef chairman and Laura
would repeat what I well what I'm saying
you know the American people in the last
election even from Trump districts said
we want to make the president
accountable a lot of people love them
they like a bit but they want to make
him accountable and we have been
stonewalled with regard to getting
information access to witnesses and and
getting documents all of us that
remember the president said I'm not you
know I'm not I'm not gonna give you
anything really and so again this the
speaker is absolutely right we we is
we're gonna we're gathering information
and we are met with with significant
force but we're on our way through but
all of that information
piece by piece it's like the mosaic
paints the picture
[Music]
I've never long said that I have never
long said that if we have a case for
impeachment that's the place we will
have to go I've got the fact that why
I'd like it to be a strong case is
because I don't it's based on the facts
the facts in the law that's what matters
not politics not partisanship just
patriotism I don't care with it I mean
I'd like to send it to be responsible
and honor their oath of office to
protect and defend the Constitution to
see the challenge this is to our
national security though the Russians
trying to do to our country but the
stronger our case is the worse the
Senate will look for just letting the
president off the hook so much I'm gonna
start asking them questions let me just
say that you give me the opportunity to
say this and then I invite my chairman
to close we want to have the strongest
possible case to make a decision as to
what path we will go down and that does
is not endless in terms of time or
endless in terms of the information that
we want but if it comes to a point where
the cone of silence and the obstruction
of justice and the cover-up in the White
House prevents us from getting that
information that will not present us
from going forward in fact is even more
grounds to go forward I just want to
just echo that you know Martin Luther
King said something that I did is in the
DNA better still in my brain
particularly right now he said there
comes a point when silence becomes
betrayal and we refused to betray
generations yet unborn and the American
people we're not going to portray them
and the more we just with accumulating
information and doing the best we can
again
with with a force as great I don't know
how many lawyers the president has but
he's got a lot of them and they go
against every single thing we do and so
again we go we've got it we're not gonna
betray America we're gonna do our part
to make sure that we have a democracy
that's intact the United States is a
democracy it must remain a democracy a
democracy acts through the elected
officials with the consent of the people
the people cannot give that consent
unless they know the facts today was a
watershed day and telling the facts to
the American people with those facts we
can proceed and we face the time of
great danger Richard Nixon said he
thought that the president was a
dictator he said if the President does
that that means it's not illegal
president Trump echoed that yesterday he